[Musique]
le mont saint michel se réveille sur ces
marches une jeune femme s'impatiente
elle s'appelle chicaco
bonjour j'espère que vous avez fait bon
voyage ce couple de japonais vient de
traverser la moitié de la planète pour
réaliser son rêve
aujourd'hui ils n'ont que 8 heures pour
revivre et immortaliser leur mariage
dans le lieu français le plus à la mode
au japon
[Musique]
le message est très beau
nous avons décidé si fou comme
[Musique]
fasciné par sa ressemblance avec
certaines de leur montagne sacrée
depuis sept ans plus de deux millions de
touristes japonais sont déjà venus au
mont saint michel
[Musique]
le mont saint michel est l'un des lieux
les plus secrets les plus saisissants et
les plus mystérieux du patrimoine
français
autrefois il y avait beaucoup plus de
français un petit peu d'anglais
d'allemand et maintenant on a le monde
entier trait d'union entre la normandie
et la bretagne ce rocher dressé à 80
mètres de hauteur ne mesure que quatre
kilomètres carrés
pourtant il attire chaque année deux
millions et demi de touristes
parmi eux sabrina son mari et leurs deux
enfants nous passerons une journée avec
eux depuis près de 1300 ans ces
monuments pour la plupart mystique
raconte notre histoire en particulier
son abbaye qui surplombe le mont xavier
bailly et le gardien des clés de cette
abbaye et quand il aménage son bureau
c'est avec un monte-charge étonnant au
mont-saint-michel en vie après
augmentation
dans les soubassements du monde nous
découvrirons sa part d'ombré
à l'extérieur en bas du rocher ceux qui
profitent de ce site toute l'année les
moutons des prés salés les herbus les
prés salés et le mont saint michel on
peut pas rêver mieux la baie du mont
saint michel est inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco depuis 40 ans
mais elle est aussi dangereuse et
surveillé 24 heures sur 24
cernée par les eaux quand la marée haute
ma mère
lorsqu'elle se retire ce sont les
risques d'enlisement qui sont nombreux
pièges ne bouge presque plus
mais ça n'arrête pas pour autant les
touristes qui affluent dans les
boutiques
j'aime bien le qu'elles
dégustent les omelettes à la recette
secrète
admire les phoques ou plus détonants
encore frissonne en se faisant tiré par
des chiens de traîneau
mais le mont saint michel est avant tout
un lieu spirituel chaque année des
milliers de pèlerins viennent s'y
ressourcer et prier devant saint michel
l'archange qui terrassa le dragon et les
protège a du mal les cons ça fait quatre
jours on marche vers le mont saint
michel
[Musique]
le soir lors des grandes marées ceux qui
vivent là sont coupés du monde cernés
par les eaux leur récompense pour cette
vie recluse c'est leur vue stupéfiante
départ immédiat dans un voyage chargé
d'histoire de saveurs et surtout de
mystère
il est 6 heures du matin une brume
ceinture le mont saint michel
shop à ses pieds comme chaque matin 400
moutons sont en route pour paître dans
ses pâturages
bien avant que les touristes arrivent le
berger yannick frein accompagne ses
moutons chaque jour depuis qu'il est
enfant
[Musique]
allez ma mère
allait
donc ici tu es c'est mon bureau
quotidien voilà
le prix staline
le prés salés un pâturage rares en
france car grâce aux embruns quotidien
son herbe est imprégné du sel de la mer
yannick est propriétaire de la moitié de
ses terres 1300 hectares de ce pré salé
couverts d'herbe qu'il appelle la plante
la particularité de cette plante ce sont
des plantes halophiles tordre qui
supporte l'eau de mer quand la marée se
retire les sels minéraux de l'yonne se
dépose sur la plante est donc à
l'ingestion de mes moutons ça va
donner une saveur à la viande qui sera
inégalable
sa viande tendre est prisé dans le monde
entier pour son goût salé sa cuisson
caramélisées et sa couleur rose et les
plus grands chefs étoilés la mettent à
leur carte une renommée qui dure depuis
cinq générations dans la famille de
yannick mon arrière grand père avait 50
moutons mon grand père avait 150 moutons
mon père 400 et puis moi et puis moins
800 et puis alexandre avec alexandre ans
né à 1000 donc voilà où s'arrêteront
nous
voici alexandre son fils ce matin il est
resté à la bergerie avec une partie du
troupeau car cette saison est celle de
la tonte il n'a que trois jours pour
tondre les 1000 brebis et béliers de
l'élevage familial leur laine est très
prisé en chine pour fabriquer des
matelas
le travail des tombeurs et minutieux ils
doivent rester au ras de la peau des
moutons avec leur tondeuse télescopique
pour ne pas blesser les animaux aux deux
minutes
25 à 30 ce travail est délicat mais il
doit être rapide car il faut tondre 340
moutons par jour pour tenir les délais
de livraison pour la chine en plus une
jeune tondeuse des buts adele fait
partie des trente femmes tondeuse en
france
c'est la première fois que j'en vois une
fille tombe c'est très courageux de sa
part et pour avoir une sacrée force dans
les bras et
le sauteur mon chapeau tout le monde
s'agite dans la bergerie les à la
fiancée d'alexandre tu as cette laine
dont raffolent les chinois
tan chaud
il n est qu un peu sableuses et un peu
un peu jaune c'est inné 0,6 et un petit
peu fois
le câble donc là dessus au piège le veut
le faire vo on va le sortir et on va
l'enlever up chaque balle au contient
l'équivalent de 40 brebis au total 2
tonnes de laine seront ramassées dans 25
ballots
de retour du pâturage yannick poste à la
touche finale de la tonte le marquage du
troupeau pour retrouver les brebis
égarées
mon arrière grand père avec comme marque
a à f bleu il était resté une tradition
tradition ancestrale donc f cofra voilà
et donc tous les moutons sont marqués à
kf2 f pour les bulles y ait un seul f
pour les brebis
[Applaudissements]
pendant que les moutons repartent au
pâturage avec la plus belle des vues
sur la passerelle de près d'un kilomètre
des navettes déversent les touristes
20000 viennent chaque jour visiter le
monde
tant sur la main et voilà servi on s'est
beaucoup à bord de l'une d'entre elles
oui
sabrina son mari et leurs deux enfants
super tu vois le drapeau normand
oui
et qui voit l'ange
à eau en or oui c'est trop beau un
cette famille habite à saint lô à 1h30
de route leur sortie préférée c'est
venir au mont-saint-michel quelle que
soit la saison il ya toujours un visage
différent selon la marée selon le temps
en hiver on été foncé c'est tout en
super junior
le mot est entourée d'eau et de vase
pour éviter les chutes de touristes
chaque matin un tracteur bros s'activent
pour nettoyer la boue
[Musique]
on approche plus faut lever la tête et
miné voulait la paix pour tous petits
oui ça fait mal au coin tellement ces
eaux
[Musique]
autrefois le mont saint michel était une
forteresse protégé par un pont-levis
juste de l'autre côté la grande rue la
rue principale du rocher
elle est belle cette fin elle est super
jolie tout petit fût elle est ferré oui
tout au long de cette rue les touristes
s'amassent autour des restaurants et des
boutiques de souvenirs et des souvenirs
il y en a dans toutes les langues pour
tous les styles
dans la famille des devinettes le jeu
continue
et là vous savez ce que c'est on voit
les statuts la palme sellali non c'est
l'archange saint michel parce qu'on est
où ici au mont saint michel
regardez là haut qui est un chevalier
[Musique]
dans les boutiques les prix s'adapte à
tous les budgets de 3 à 200 euros avec
un tas de produits à l'effigié du mont
saint michel face à tant de tentations
les enfants trouvent évidemment leur
bonheur bien sûr tu prends la robe
on a déjà pu
apprendre à passer tu aimes bien lequel
tu lui la sellerie qu'à dépenser 12
euros le panier moyen des dépenses des
touristes est d'environ 15 euros
devant la boutique la patronne profite
d'un rare moment de calme pour remettre
son stand en place
elle s'appelle noël poignant et elle
dirige ce magasin depuis 60 ans
c'est toujours été très attiré d'abord
par l'abbaye par le site
la preuve c'est que je vais avoir 80 ans
et je suis toujours là je n'arrive pas à
prendre ma retraite comme tous les jours
elle se tient à sa place préférée dehors
sur le pas de sa porte si vous voulez
entrer tant sur la marche c'est un très
bon au classement parce que je suis à la
fois la dernière est la première en
descendant
avec presque 3 millions de touristes
annuels qui passe devant sa boutique son
commerce est florissant
ce qu'elle préfère parce qu'ils
dépensent le plus ce sont les japonais
par ce jeu
oscourt discuter au revoir sa mort entre
dans la boutique derrière ces assiettes
une porte secrète
poster dans ma cuisine
voilà y'a pas de places de perdues vous
avez vu même sur la porte yade elle a
des objets
les maisons habitables sur le mont saint
michel sont rares tout se ressemble tout
en hauteur plutôt petit étroites tout
collées les unes aux autres tout
mitoyenne noël ne vit pas dans cette
maison de 50 m²
c'est son petit fils qui habite la pièce
principale et aujourd'hui n'est pas une
journée comme les autres gabriel est
dans le journal local
maman chérie je suis très fier d'être
couvrir ça dans un journal c'est très
fière de toi comme toujours
en grand
si gabriel a eu droit à un article c'est
parce qu'il est un véritable passionné
d'histoire
depuis trois mois cet étudiant en
tourisme et patrimoine répertorie tous
les objets qui ont appartenu aux
habitants du rocher il les listes et
raconte leur histoire
je suis arrivé
de 249
pour trouver ces 249 objet il a commencé
par ouvrir les albums photos de sa grand
mère
donc c'est cet homme arrière-grand-père
ça c'est un arrière grand mère c'était
pour le théâtre alors en fait c'est
mademoiselle provost qui faisait la mise
en scène de petites pièces de théâtre
pour les montois pour les occuper
l'hiver noël est incollable sur le monde
elle l'a découvert à 20 ans à l'époque
elle vit près de cherbourg
le nouveau mont-saint-michel en 1960 tu
es venu en vacances chez mon oncle
françois ai dit tu veux faire de la
voile ben je te présenter à nos toits il
ya un bateau et de pourra faire de la
voile a vécu voilà c'est comme ça que
j'ai connus pour fait son canton grand
pont six mois plus tard noël épouse
claude son petit copain de voile l'homme
et commerçants et permet à noël
d'acheter sa propre petite boutique
à l'époque les biens appartiennent à
l'évêché et ne sont pas bon marché
c'est la photo de mariage civil on en
sort de la mairie depuis six générations
la famille du mari de noël est installé
sur le mont gabriel son unique petit
fils est fier de ses racines
fait cent cinquante ans qu'on est sur le
sol allemand saint-michel ça peut
paraître beaucoup mais plusieurs
anciennes familles depuis plus de 500
ans qui sont qui sont ici topolanek g7
photo l'air quand la passerelle en bois
était recouverte et les en partie les
touristes comme ça et quand la
passerelle en bois n'était pas
recouvertes ils mettaient leur
cuissardes et c'était les hommes sur les
épaules elle est femme dans les bras
c'est marrant comme comme anecdote
aujourd'hui sur le mont à par les
touristes en fait voilà peu de choses
ont changé
la chance qu'on a d'avoir cette terrasse
il est impossible de pousser les murs
des maisons qui reste petit mais sur
cette terrasse grand-mère et petit-fils
saisissent la chance d'être seul pour
admirer une vue unique au monde au calme
car en bas à l'entrée du mont c'est
l'agitation les livraison matinale
s'enchaînent pour les commerces et les
restaurants
au milieu des autres camions jean-paul
décharge ses caisses remplies de deux
fois par semaine il est l'un des rares à
pouvoir se garer au pied du rocher effet
venue des centaines de fois
j'éprouve toujours le même grand bonheur
quand j'arrive je le trouve toujours
aussi beau tour aussi majestueuse pour
moi c'est un bonheur dans la ville de
livrer loin saint michel mais au mont
saint michel les livraisons ne sont pas
de tout repos il faut parfois grimper
sur 300 mètres et réussir à se frayer un
chemin parmi la foule
pardon
depuis 29 ans jean paul est le
producteur des oeufs de l'auberge de la
mère poulard le premier restaurant que
l'on voit en arrivant le plus célèbre
aussi pour ses hommes net pour que ce
thème comment ça va
et toi ça va
tu veux
christine l homme laitière de l'auberge
les 1440 livrés seront tous servis à
midi mais avant christine doit les
ranger dans sa pièce secrète celle de la
préparation de l'omelette
certain nombre
non je peux rien dire non non vous
verrez par vous même en service ce matin
christine est pressée elle a rendez vous
avec sacha un nouvel apprenti elle doit
former
bonjour bonjour cédric je te présente
sacha le métier bonjour sourire
oui
allez c'est parti dans cette auberge une
bonne omelette commence dans de grandes
bassines en cuivre qui doivent toujours
être impeccable selon les faits tous les
jours deux fois par jour sacha et
serveurs il vient de bretagne et pour
son premier jour en cuisine il ne
s'imaginait pas à récurer des culs de
poules va maintenant tous frottent
jusqu'à temps que ça brille et je te
sors les autres
c'est dans ces saladier zar on dit qu'il
faudra battre les oeufs
pourquoi il était invasive on va voir
que tu as des bons mois le jeune homme
de 22 ans est venue tenter sa chance à
l'auberge pour apprendre un métier qu'on
trouve seulement au mont saint michel
tu peux pas être déçue entrevoyons mon
spectacle du plaisir c'est une belle vue
tous les jours tu croises des nouvelles
personnes nouvelle nationalité ou
l'origine
d'une richesse que tu trouve pas
ailleurs ça y est c'est bon ou pas fini
c'est bien toi regarde son gré sacha n'a
pas beaucoup de temps pour parler car
christine est tout le temps pressait à
l'extérieur les touristes affluent déjà
pour voir l'omelette christine doit
mettre une barrière de sécurité pour les
contenir elle doit se changer le service
va commencer
mon chef m'a bien
oui je me dépêche
[Musique]
non je suis désolé pardon non on ne peut
pas rentrer parce que ça ne peut-il pas
de secret d'accord
les proportions avec ou sans sel avec ou
sans sucre nous ne saurons rien des
secrets de fabrication de l'omelette de
la mère poulard
regrettes tu prennes blanche tu pars dit
si tu utilises tout on fouille pour
rentrer un maximum d'air l'accord était
d aller retour allait passer si tu as
mal c'est normal pas facile de débuter
la technique est complexe et douloureuse
christine en sait quelque chose à force
de fouetter dix heures par jour au fil
des ans son poignet s'est déformée trois
premières mesures
[Musique]
arrivé il ya 30 ans elle est l'unique
femme en cuisine et perpétuent la
tradition d'annette poulard la créatrice
de l'auberge il y à 130 ans cette femme
a eu l'ingénieuse idée d'offrir une
omelette ou pèlerins arrivés au mont
saint michel
et para qu'elle avait son caractère
optique j'ai par contre un grand club
c'est un mythe quand même allez trouver
la mère poulard c'est cette tradition
est devenue une affaire rentable
l'homme l'aide de la mère poulard est
l'attraction du monde sûrement aussi
pour la musique de ces fouet sur les
bassines
cette musique
mais la tradition c'est pas son talent
que les gens qui viennent ici pour
trouver le rythme et reproduire cette
petite musique n'est pas une mince
affaire
pour réussir à battre en cadence sacha
devra s'entraîner pendant un mois
environ et en plus c'est des bulles vont
être photographiés tout au long de la
journée par les touristes
quand un père du poupon star la star au
phénomène
je suis une forêt de jambes l'est
légumes et l'omelette st jacques 3 oui
chez la mère poulard chaque omelette et
nature les clients peuvent s'y ajouter
les ingrédients qu'il souhaite elle est
cuite au feu de bois pendant cinq
minutes pour obtenir cette texture
généreuse et onctueuse
c'est chaud les assiettes chef
[Musique]
coloré
de l'autre côté du mur la salle affiche
complet et surprise
à table nous retrouvons à ica et hiroki
le couple de jeunes mariés japonais ils
ont prolongé leur séjour d'une nuit et
ne pouvait pas repartir au japon sans
goûter la célèbre boule est de la mère
poulard
à 38 euros l'omelette l'addition est
salée mais rares sont les déçus
oui chef
en cuisine après trois heures de
bataille non-stop je te remercie
beaucoup pour ton aide allez au revoir
non c'est très très bien débrouillé le
gamin il a rien dit et s'est pas plaint
donc j'ai une très bonne impression 3
je suis contente avec christine ils
auront préparé près de 300 omelette en
trois heures
il est 15 heures la marée s'est retiré
les touristes continuent d'affluer
certains d'entre eux ont envie de
s'amuser dans la vase
sabrina son mari et leurs deux enfants
ont réservé un guide car tout autour du
monde c'est toujours plus prudent d'être
avec un enfant du pays
je vous conseille en fait de vous
déplacer pieds nus matin puis comme vous
le voyez en fait le seul est plutôt
argileux glaiseux glissant et en fait ça
sera beaucoup plus facile plus area
moins salissant meilleur pour le chlore
de marché et à cela vous pouvez associer
le ventre entre est l'effet serait la
poitrine en avant
ce qui vous permettra dans le pire des
cas à savoir si vous chutez d'une chute
avec une certaine dignité
donc bonne chance à vous
[Musique]
l'envy de tous ces touristes est de se
faire un peu peur dans la vase
[Musique]
au sol un sable vaseux que l'on appelle
tang et qui reste collé au pied
[Musique]
reste côté plateau
rafa tu regarde cette photo
nous en ferons ce n'est pas vraiment ça
raphaël le fils n'est qu'au début de ses
surprises car tous approche des sables
mouvants
regardez là vous vous enfoncez
légèrement
mais vous vous enfoncez en dessous vous
allez trouver une matière dure un sable
mouvant si vous voulez c'est totalement
l'inversé c'est d'abord dur vous pouvez
marcher dessus sans même savoir que vous
êtes sur un sable mouvant dangereux avec
prudence tous se lancent derrière romain
le guide
en fait c'est moi qui ai initié michael
jackson ça lui a pas du tout réussi
je sais pas si vous le remarquez là sous
mes pieds ça y est là je sens si vous
l'êtes le sol il bouge comme ça je me
suis pas encore remisé en à peine 30
secondes le guide s'enfonce ses jambes
disparaissent tout doucement
d'envoyer ses c'est quand même assez
progressif d'accord mais là en fait je
suis loin d'être au maximum le principal
problème d'un sable mouvant c'est après
de dégager regardez si j'essaie de
partir vite oui je reste bloquée
donc en fait pour se dégager n'y a
qu'une solution c'est de sortir
progressivement jambe par jean soit vous
vous allongez carrément dans la boue
soit vous remontez sur les genoux
voyez
alors ça fait de magnifiques me bats
c'est très sexy c'est désormais au tour
des touristes d'affronter les sables
mouvants
il faut sauter pour casser le sable afin
que l'eau du dessous s'infiltre et
rendent la balle molle ça amuse beaucoup
cédric le mari de sabrina
bah oui
c'est spécial
cédric s'enfonce rapidement
sûrement plus vite qu'ils ne le
pensaient
les gens ont l'impression d'être dans du
béton là en fait ça s'est durci tout
autant
[Musique]
cédric ne rigole plus le père de famille
est prise au piège fait je pense que je
peux je peux sortir que par moi même
[Musique]
en pleine bouche parce qu
ils essayent de sortir masi n'y arrive
pas en fait cédric n'a pas écouté les
consignes du guide
[Musique]
alors
voilà là vous avez un parfait cas
d'enlisement là si vous voulez vous
pouvez pas vous enfoncer plus bouger
est-ce que la jambe droite et fait ça et
mettez la en avant vous la plier voilà
et vous ne peut en avant et maintenant
vous faites parler avec la gauche et
vous sortez faut sortir jambe par jambes
et progressivement
après cinq minutes à se débattre cédric
dégage enfin ses jambes
soient mieux oui on sent plus enfin plus
léger
mais pas le temps de souffler raphaël
sont lise à son tour réplique bon je te
pied gauche depuis
12h06 père et enfants se sont amusés en
revanche il y en a une qui n'a pas voulu
s'enfoncer je préfère pas de risque je
les ai vu ça m'a bien fait rire femmes
suffit ce que ne savent peut-être pas
sabrina et ses enfants c'est qu'ils sont
de toute façon surveiller
au loin dans la tour nord avec ses
jumelles mylène veille sur les touristes
non accompagnés à la proche de la marée
elle est pompier volontaire
ça peut être dangereux quand la marée au
moins parce que ces personnels ne nous
voient pas que la marée remonte ils
peuvent se retrouver encerclés donc
c'est notre rôle de s'assurer que
personne soit dans la baie le temps que
la marée haute
la baie du mont saint michel classé
parmi les plus belles du monde est aussi
l'une des plus dangereuses après
l'enlisement le risque le plus courant
c'est la noyade
chaque année quand la marée remonte une
dizaine de visiteurs imprudent sont
évacués en urgence
vise leader de visiteurs actuellement
en sécurité
et si aucun incident n'est à déclarer
dans la baie
à la caserne les pompiers sont appelés
en intervention avec 20000 visiteurs par
jour les risques d'accident sont
fréquents à l'intérieur du monde quentin
florian et rodolphe vous partez à
l'abbaye aussi haut niveau
sur le rocher toutes les interventions
se font à pied et à travers des
escaliers
un vrai parcours sportif
on sait qui tu sais qui c'est vous
bonjour
avec ce sac est tombé
voulu nous montrer ouais les yeux je me
suis cette jeune fille qui les a appelés
est embêté de les déranger pour si peu
mais elle vient de faire tomber son sac
150 marches plus tard
ce soir là à la surprise générale il ne
s'agit pas d'un sac à main mais d'un sac
en papier d'une boutique de souvenirs
dans lequel elle a laissé un foulard
auquel elle tient beaucoup
avec mon copain on prenait des photos et
c est en fait avec le vent on n'a pas
réalisé on avait vu sac partir
directement est tombée trois mètres plus
bas au monde toute intervention peut
devenir inédite
les pompiers doivent s'adapter à toutes
les situations comme dans ce cas précis
où il faut récupérer un foulard le
pompiers munis d'une gaffe une sorte de
grande canne à pêche va tenter
d'attraper le sac
l'opération ressemble à une partie de
pêche à la ligne le jeune pompier très
habile à trac le sable du premier coup
sous le regard admiratif des touristes
bonjour et au revoir la jeune femme
retrouve le sourire soulagé elle va
pouvoir repartir avec son précieux
foulard agent de stars une super bien
belle expérience 55 michel ça se finit
bien
[Musique]
de retour à la caserne une autre équipe
part pour un cas qui semble plus grave
prends tu n'as
pas les
bons atouts
en bas des marches de l'abbaye une
personne vient de faire un malaise
cette dame a perdu connaissance dans les
escaliers elle s'est assise et n'a pas
pu se relever à cause de la douleur sans
plus tarder les pompiers lui prodiguent
les premiers soins pour déterminer
l'urgence de l'intervention
facturation à 99% un pou à 62 et la
plupart de nos interventions souvent
c'est dû à des un effort physique
puisque mont saint michel s'est
énormément de marche contient un effort
physique et les gens à force de monter
la chaleur en plus aujourd'hui
peut déclencher ce genre de magasin oak
est public symétrique réactive la lgv a
pas de douleur qui réapparaît
n'entend que je vais par monter des
escaliers mais je pars montée
mais à partir du moment où cette dame a
perdu connaissance les pompiers ne sont
pas qualifiés pour prendre une décision
médicale
c'est le médecin du samu qui donne son
diagnostic
madame g le médecin régulateur au samu
donc y'a pas de soucis on va vous
laisser là d'accord pour partir
tranquillement ou et puis c'était moins
de soucis ce qu'on pourrait appeler le
j'aime à ce passage à les y maintenir un
peu le poids des toiles
[Musique]
moi je ne vois pas
mais bon
[Musique]
malgré son petit accident françoise
garde un bon souvenir de son passage sur
le rocher c'est un peu présumé de mes
forces aujourd'hui enfin l'essentiel
c'est le jeune j'ai vu quand même le
mont saint michel
aumont les pompiers interviennent toute
l'année
l'hiver pour les chutes à cause du
verglas sur les marches
l'été c'est souvent à l'abbaye que la
plupart des accidents arrivent car les
variations de température son redoutable
chaud dehors très frais de dents
sur un seul
jour jérémy bels et bien
tant mieux
cet homme avec son imposant trousseau de
clés est le seul qui peut ouvrir les 252
portes du monument la chose en train
d'ouvrir une porte que l'on ouvre qu'en
certaines occasions pour accéder à
l'escalier de dentelle un petit lieu
presque secret
[Musique]
perché à 90 mètres de hauteur on appelle
cet escalier l'escalier de dentelle pour
ce garde-corps ciselé dans la pierre
[Musique]
en empruntant l'escalier de dentelle on
s'approche du personnage le plus
important du mont saint michel
l'archange bien sûr il est ici au dessus
de nous sur la flèche à 156 mètres
d'altitude
xavier bailly l administrateur de
l'abbaye il est le gardien de son
histoire est un privilégié il peut
ouvrir les pièces secrètes
habituellement fermés au public
envoie dans la flèche alors la flèche
c'est quand même le petit balcon qu'elle
a au frais pour l' aventure
mais
après avoir grimpé l'équivalent de six
étages la flèche le point culminant du
mont saint michel perché à 140 mètres de
hauteur pour ça se mérite
nous sommes ici dans ce que l'on appelle
le belvédère avec une très très belle
vue plongeante sur la terrasse de
l'ouest sur la merveille on voit bien le
cloître on voit tout le village au fil
des époques les occupants de l'abbaye
ont laissé leurs empreintes guerre de
cent ans occupation nazie une partie de
l'histoire de france est ancré ici il
s'agit de graffitis allemand de la
seconde guerre mondiale quand le mont
saint michel était occupé on a ici la
date de 1942 et ce graffiti comme
beaucoup d'autres ici dans la flèche ont
été barrées par les libérateurs
américains après la libération de la
norme
quelques étages plus bas dans les
sous-sols une nouvelle facette de son
passé plus sombre encore sommes à la
porte des cachots de l'abbaye du
mont-saint-michel sommes pas dans la
période la plus pas dire la plus faste
ni la plus brillante l'histoire du mont
saint michel mais c'est se rappeler
aussi que l'abbaye du mont saint michel
a été une prison à partir de la
révolution française et qui ont été
enfermés ici des prêtres réfractaires
des chouans et des prisonniers
politiques comme barbès
entre 1793
1863 c'est plus de 14 mille détenus qui
sont enfermés à l'abbaye du mont saint
michel
mais depuis 1300 en l'abbaye est avant
tout un lieu spirituel
d'après la légende l'origine de l'église
abbatiale remonte à l'an 709 dans un
rêve l'archange saint-michel rend visite
à l'évêque saint-aubert et lui demande
de construire un sanctuaire à son nom
c'est par ce rêve que débute l'histoire
religieuse du mont saint michel
l'abbaye sur laquelle règne xavier est
un lieu au passé chargé mais l'homme est
aussi très ancrée dans le présent et il
a maintenant une mission bien délicate
car sur le mont les choses les plus
simples peuvent devenir très compliqué
bonjour olivier
henrard faille et vous avez des chaises
bonjour bon vous faites attention à ce
que c'est quand même du philippe starck
il faut quand même faire attention ces
chaises design cent pour son bureau non
moi je les aurais mis dans l'autre sens
non
ça va aller pour les rayer pas trop
au moindre objet mail placé dans le
monde charge c'est le risque de chute
au monde depuis des siècles tous les
emménagements et déménagement d'objets
lourds ou encombrants se font avec un
monte-charge
à l'origine c'était avec cette rampe en
pierre
tout ici a recours à des moyens tout à
fait exceptionnel le treuil où
l'hélicoptère on sait bon olivier vous
êtes prêt à lancer au quai
vallet vous allez dire que je les trouve
bien précieux au ses chaises mais bon
pour récupérer ses chaises xavier doit
faire deux fois le tour de l'abbaye est
monté une centaine de marches
photo et sont arrivés
quand on approche au mont saint michel
que ce soit pour les chantiers
l'entretien la maintenance ou la vie
quotidienne envie appelant de montagne
ici
dijoux la sphère
livraison sans accroc mais pour xavier
le chemin est encore long pour arriver à
son bureau il a traversé l'église
abbatiale comme raccourci et arrive
enfin
ça y est les fauteuils sont enfin
arrivés
[Musique]
bon
ben si vous collier
devant son bureau xavier a lui aussi une
terrasse qui surplombe cette baie de 500
kilomètres carrés
elle compte une dizaine de plages où
l'on peut se baigner l'été sur certaines
d'entre elles on découvre des activités
étonnante
voilà allez on va attendre la famille
qui va bientôt arriver
la famille que didier attend est celle
de sabrina
[Musique]
bonjour huawei
didier est un musher l'hiver il vit à la
montagne mais il y a trois ans il est
tombé amoureux de la baie du mont saint
michel et il a adapté son savoir faire
or le sable par rapport à la neige
disons qu'il n'ya pas le contact du
froid mais au niveau des appuis ça reste
identique vous avez le sable non
mouillée qui ressemble à peu la
poudreuse et le sable mouillé qui
ressemblent à des pistes damées
rapprocher chaque jour il propose aux
enfants de faire des tours de traîneau
sur la plage avec ses 8 femelle husky
mais aujourd'hui certaines n'ont pas
très envie de partir en balade
sur le sable les chiens de traîneaux ne
peuvent pas supporter plus de 70 kg il
faut donc qu'ils allaient un parent
je suis dans le crime du père noël
c'est bien la fête est prêt allez on va
y aller doucement à boucher des champs
pas bougé
pas bouger les skis sont dissipés stop
stop
allez
l'histoire
la balade dure 15 minutes
[Musique]
et sous
soit
[Musique]
/
c'est trop bien augustin peut bien pour
trop bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est sûr que si on pouvait le faire
aussi on aurait bien fait et puis c'est
pas habituel de voir des chiens de
traîneau sur la plage donc ça accès que
c'est super
c'était la dernière attraction de la
famille de sabrina ils vont rentrer chez
eux et le rocher va de nouveau
ressembler un îlot perdu au milieu de la
mer
les commerçants ferment boutique
[Musique]
et le gardien des clés son abbaye
alors là on est enfin sur une clé tout à
fait secrète et très personnel c'est là
qu'habite
il est l'un des 32 derniers habitants du
mont saint michel
tu m'apportes oui sérieux ça arrive ça
arrive
il vit seul ici avec son chat ses lunes
elles habitent à l'année ici comme moi
sa maison est entourée d'un jardin
privatif une maison de fonction de 180
m² avec 5 chambres qui l'a entièrement
aménagé avec ses propres meubles
nous voici dans la salle à manger de la
maison verte
c'est vraiment là là que je vis à
l'année que je travaille encore un peu
aussi
la seule chose que j'ai trouvé en
arrivant dans cette maison c'est le
tableau qui fait partie des collections
dhabi et qui remonte présente le mont
saint michel dans les dernières
décennies du xviiie siècle après avoir
été responsable du patrimoine d'amiens
il s'est porté candidat pour le poste
d'administrateur de l'abbaye du mont
saint michel il avait envie de tester
l'expérience d'une vie solitaire est
recluse
une fois passé le tumulte de la journée
s'instaure une forme de calme de
quiétude voire même de solitude
il y a quelque chose de monastique dans
la vie quotidienne au mont-saint-michel
oui
xavier travail et y vit depuis quatre
ans il ne sait pas quand sa mission
prendra fin ce monde il en rêvait depuis
toujours cette vie solitaire il a appris
à l'aimer et parfois il redoute son
prochain post car rien ne pourra jamais
ressembler à 7
l'autre personnage qui rêvait
secrètement d'exercer ici c'est cet
homme qui se glisse entre les murs voilà
bon allez
c'est un peu juste ça va
ça va depuis la dernière fois je me suis
pas trop étoffé gravats
riton est le prêtre de l'église du mont
saint michel chaque fois qu'il en a
l'occasion
il passe par la rue des cocus la rue la
plus étroite du monde on raconte que
seuls les hommes fidèles peuvent la
traversée mais il ya des touristes cette
fois qu'il reste coincé mais pas moi en
quoi ça viendra peut-être mais pas pour
l'instant
adossé au rocher son église se trouve à
gauche de la grande rue juste avant
l'abbaye c'est l'église paroissiale du
monde un lieu d'accueil pour les
pèlerins et hourrite on se rend tous les
jours pour aider les gens
je fais ce que je peux simplement pour
que le mal ne soit pas trop fort c'est
tout voilà j'essaye le plus simplement
possible de lui dire de s'écarter des
gens qu'on voit là il y rencontre toutes
sortes de visiteurs venus implorer la
protection de l'archange devant sa
chapelle il y dépose toute sorte
d'objets parfois surprenants d'après la
légende saint michel a terrassé le
dragon il a vaincu le mal et protège les
fidèles
[Musique]
et
chaque jour riton célèbre la messe
et à la fin de la messe c'est souvent le
même type de demande cette femme
originaire de nevers a fait cinq heures
de route pour faire bénir les objets de
son père décédé
venez on va là la sacristie venait
le nez
mais spécialement que ce soit béni s'il
se sent il voulait que ça soit béni ici
plus spécialement
voit la paille bénéat seigneur snedai
cette croix de cette chaîne et accorde à
ce qu'ils les importerons te restait
toujours fidèle que saint michel vénéré
dans ce sanctuaire nous bénisse et nous
protège qui nous accorde sa force et son
soutien au nom du père du fils et du
saint esprit amen tandis que riton béni
les médailles 400 personnes arrivent les
pieds dans la vase le mont saint michel
n'est pas qu'un lieu touristique il est
aussi un lieu de pèlerinage parmi elles
23 pèlerins silencieux ils sont
catholiques musulmans juifs protestants
et viennent ensemble de marchés 120 km
pour prier au mont saint michel dans le
plus grand mystère
riton les accueillent il ouvre une
vieille boîte une récompense pour leur
courage et leur endurance
[Musique]
aller
voilà
c'est le trésorier la couronne de saint
michel
à c'est tout
un art à l'origine cette couronne était
en or cet ep aussi ainsi que ce collier
et ce bouclier
si les pèlerins ont le privilège de
tenir ces objets c'est parce que ce ne
sont que des copies les originaux ont
été volés il y a près de deux siècles
c'est pour ça il y avait beaucoup de
deux bandes et sur les routes je vous en
avais pas vu les bordiers
face à tant de beauté les pèlerins de la
france entière chante à la gloire de
saint michel
[Musique]
tu démarres
y avait cinq horloges
il y avait ça louis
cabeza michael
mais surtout il ne veut aller vous mont
saint michel
demain ils reprendront leur marche
spirituelle
mais avant ils dormiront sur le monde
enveloppez comme chaque nuit d'un
manteau de bruyn